frozen Arctic soil called permafrost
holds more than a trillion tons of
carbon as the dirt thaws that carbon
escapes as greenhouse gases scientists
say this melting could supercharge
global warming I see only one way it's
necessary Nietzsche great melting of
permafrost Sergey Zim off has been
studying the permafrost for decades to
stop the permafrost from thawing he has
a radical notion to recreate the Arctic
of 30 thousand years ago
implies the sensor was millions of
meters of herbivores which ITA's is
grass all veinte veinte gates very long
the moths goal was to transform mossy
tundra and forests like this in the
grasslands so 18 years ago here was like
the place we've just been in now
well you see that the dormant is grass
they are recreating the mammoth steppe
ecosystem that once dominated the high
latitudes the first experiments is
starting the Soviet type we bought some
horses we built small plants the animals
kill trees and shrubs and stimulate
grasses by grazing and fertilizing them
surveys son
Nikita brings a group of students into a
permafrost cave to show the connection
30 metres below the surface one
appreciates the massive size of this
carbon rich soil
how can you cool the first more you
remove the insulation away how can you
do that like you can either take a
bulldozer and bulldoze entire Arctic
everywhere we can't let anyone do that
themselves
Oh horses for example excavate snow for
fightback novita by disrupting the snow
and exposing soil to the arctic air the
animals keep the permafrost 2 degrees
colder than it would have been otherwise
animals from all over Asia now graze in
Pleistocene Park yaku daeun horses from
this region of Siberia musk ox from
wrangle island in the Arctic Ocean local
hunters provide moose and the Zim ops
hope other Pleistocene parks will be
created to protect permafrost across the
world and we see if it's competence
mortality its you covered in the
annotated Lee many thousand years you
must fight his wild and main enemy of
humans it's also wild animals
by allowing animals to transform the
Arctic and protect permafrost the Zima
offs want to change the relationship
between humans and animals this ik
assist impossible recover
you